-Holidays coming up.
Will you spend Thanksgiving
with your family?
-Yes. We celebrate. We go
to the beach in North Carolina.
My brother David
bought us a house,
which we call "The Sea Section."
[ Laughter ]
And we do a -- we do a
Mediterranean Thanksgiving,
´cause my dad´s 94,
and we´re Greek.
And so now we just make
a big Greek --
-And any family traditions,
other than the Mediterranean?
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
I turn the living room
into spa night,
and I give everybody a facial.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
-And I hire my sister in-law,
who does all the work,
and I´m very abusive to her.
[ Laughter ]
It´s just for "entertainment."
-Yeah.
-And I never give her
a cut of the money.
-Okay.
-And then my niece helps me
with the invitations.
And everyone just complains.
-Oh, that´s wonderful.
-You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-But then, they´re sound asleep
by the end of the night,
and I really don´t know
what I´m doing.
But, I mean, you know,
I have good skin in my family.
-Yeah.
-No one ever moisturizes,
you know?
-Uh-huh.
-So...
-Right. They want --
They want that tape nose skin.
-Yeah, they want
the tape nose skin.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-So I love doing it. It´s great.
-Do you have any tips
on entertaining
during the holidays -- do you --
when you have people over?
-Well, I always say, you know,
just be prepared.
And, you know,
there will be some accidents.
But just take
a Polaroid picture of it
and laugh at it in a few years.
[ Light laughter ]
But I always hate it
when you go to someone´s house
and they invite you
for Thanksgiving
and you walk in
and the raw Turkey
is sitting out on the counter.
You´re like, "Damn it. I don´t
want to be here for five hours!"
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-That´s not fair.
-No, it´s not. No.
-That is not fair.
And then you´re -- they
just encourage you to drink,
and then they have cheese balls
and snacks,
and then you´re stuffed.
-That´s the problem --
my biggest --
and I hold myself accountable.
The amount of, like, early dairy
you eat on Thanksgiving.
-Of early dairy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Like, you know, it´s like...
-Yes.
-..."Oh, dinner´s gonna be ready
in two -- two hours."
And you´re like, "Well, then,
I´ll eat a pound of cheese,
and then I´ll be very happy."
[ Laughter ]
"I´ll be in a great mood
later on."
-Yes, you´re so right.
It is a pound of cheese.
-You -- I hear that you --
you keep things in your fridge
that are not food
that you then gift?
-Oh, I like to have some artwork
in my refrigerator.
-Okay, so why -- why -- why?
-Because, "A," it´s always nice
when you open your refrigerator
and you see that cut-off hand --
you know, you get them
at Halloween stores.
It´s just a hand that´s cut off,
but they --
they wrap it really nice.
It´s like from Chop Shop or
something -- that name´s bad.
But it´s in nice Saran Wrap.
And then I have a nice --
-So that´s just a thing
that you have
that you want other people
to see, or you take joy?
-Well, I showed it to my godson,
and I saw the look on his face,
and I just --
just changed the subject.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-He was --
Yeah, that was not cool.
I mean, yeah.
-That wasn´t -- yeah.
And that´s not something
he can unsee.
-No, I moved it to the freezer.
It´s cool.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but it is nice
when you open it up,
and you can see artwork.
I have a nice fake milk carton.
I have some fake butter boxes
that I made.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-And it doesn´t -- it doesn´t
take up valuable fridge space?
-No.
-Oh, that´s good.
-I just have lettuce in there
for Tina, really.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, great.
Well, I don´t know
how to tell you this,
based on her carpet...
-Thanks.
-...but I don´t know
if she loves lettuce.
[ Laughter ]
-I know, really high piles.
-So you -- you´ve been on
a lot of television shows.
This is the first time
you are running your own show.
-Yes.
-I have -- Do you love it?
-I liked it, but it was like --
you know, well, first thing,
doing all those characters,
I realized, "Wow," you know.
I didn´t realize
I had to memorize
both sides of the script.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
So that was like --
- Right, ´cause you interact
with the characters themselves.
-Right. Then I´m like,
"Oh, what was I thinking?"
But you know
what I learned most?
I´m not kidding --
it´s this e-mail etiquette...
-Okay.
-...you know, that people have.
I just learned how to
"reply all."
[ Light laughter ]
Or, you know,
whose name goes first.
And people pay attention
to that stuff.
It never even entered my mind to
think about that kind of stuff.
-What -- Like, how -- What do
you mean about "reply all"?
You never had any reason
until you had your own show?
-I just reply.
I don´t reply all.
And then,
I hate it when people reply all,
and then you open your e-mail,
it´s like, "K,"
or, "Thanks. Awesome."
[ Light laughter ]
I mean, don´t bother me.
-Yeah.
-My mom´s motto was,
"Don´t bother other people."
-In general?
-I think that´s a good --
Yeah, don´t bother other people.
-Is that -- Was that something
when you were kids?
-How excited you are,
like there´s something deep.
-Well, no. No, I don´t mean
there´s something deep,
but, like, as kids,
were you under instructions
not to be a bother to people?
-Well, no.
We -- My mom --
Yeah, you just
don´t bother other --
We could bother each other,
I guess,
and we could bother our parents.
We just don´t bother.
You know, like,
when someone comes to your house
and they say,
"Do you have any scissors?"
It´s like, "You know I do."
[ Laughter ]
I have a craft book out.
Just ask me where they are.
Don´t ask me
if I have them there.
It just puts me in a bad mood.
-Yeah.
-And I want to stab them
with it, you know?
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I have another one
that I can tell you...
-Oh.
-...is when people say,
"Can I ask you a question?"
-Oh, yeah.
-´Cause that´s
already a question.
-Yes, yes, right.
[ Light laughter ]
-So they´ve already taken the
leap of asking me a question.
-Yeah, right.
-Or else they
wouldn´t have said it.
-And then you ask it, and then
they say, "No, you cannot ask."
And you´re just, "All right.
That´s some Whitney Houston..."
you know.
And she does that
in the documentary.
-Oh, she does?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Oh, that´s great.
-It´s a great documentary.
-The Whitney Houston
documentary?
-Yeah, it´s fun.
-Is it recent?
-Yeah, it´s recent.
-Okay.
-And the George Michael one.
I´m in documentary mode.
-The George Michael one,
I´ve heard, is fantastic.
-Yeah, it really is.
-Yeah.
-I think they leave some stuff
out, but I guess you have to.
-Yeah.
-But I like it because
it´s about a singer, you know?
They´re just out there,
by themselves, performing.
That´s interesting. But
I guess you do it every night.
-Not like George Michael
or Whitney Houston.
-Okay. Come on. Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-No, just on a talent level,
like, that´s the thing.
People who said they watched
the George Michael documentary
were overwhelmed by how --
exactly how talented he was.
-Yeah, and how ambitious.
-Yeah.
-Like when you´re little, be
like, "I want to be a big star."
-Yeah.
I guess I wouldn´t --
I feel like
I´d be less interested
in watching a documentary
about comedians.
-Right, right, right.
-Because then I would --
anybody who said, like --
Any time I would see somebody
working really hard,
I´d be like,
"Oh, I should work harder."
-[ Laughing ] I know, right?
-Whereas, like, when I --
when you watch Whitney Houston
or George Michael and be like,
"Oh, I never had that voice."
I would never, yeah.
-Yeah.
Wow, what a voice.
-What a voice.
-Also, he´s somebody who
I did not quite understand --
you know,
when he sadly passed away,
I had no sense of
what a wonderful person he was.
-Yeah, same here.
-I feel like
I´d missed all that,
and then I felt really bad,
but also, you know,
very impressed
with the kind of guy he was.
-Right. Plus,
he passed away on Christmas Day.
-I didn´t realize that.
-Mm-hmm.
Christmas Day.
-Well --
-I guess last year.
-Yeah.
-But you´re gonna --
Your parents are coming in town
for Thanksgiving?
-My parents
are gonna come to town.
They´re gonna be on this show
on Thursday.
-Okay, and then
will you go to New Hampshire
to have Thanksgiving?
-No, they´re gonna stay here
in the city.
-Oh, will you go to a
restaurant, or you gonna cook?
-No, we´re gonna have them
at our apartment.
-Oh, and you´re gonna cook,
or did you --
-My wife´s gonna cook.
-Are you gonna do anything?
-I´m not gonna do anything...
-Okay, that´s okay.
-...because I´m doing a show,
yeah.
-Oh, oh, oh, oh.
[ Laughter ]
So you´re not gonna do anything
ahead of time,
or when you get home,
you have one thing to do?
-I --
-Nothing. You´re off the hook.
-I feel like the way
you´re saying this
makes me feel really bad
about it,
and I´m gonna try to --
-No, no.
I think that´s great.
I´m not doing any cooking.
I´m not gonna do anything,
either, you know?
-I know, but I will.
I´ll try to find one thing.
Maybe I´ll bring, like,
a cheese ball or something.
[ Laughter ]